bonjour Sandrine Gomez bonjour Damien
c'est l'un des sujets qui fait la une de
la presse française ce matin et oui ce
matin aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs
syndicats la CGT FSU et solidaire qui
appelle thalagre pour la revalorisation
des salaires face à l'inflation les
travailleurs en ont donc marre de payer
l'écotaxé titre libération ce matin
regardez toutes les professions sont
concernées en effet Damien les salaires
ne suivent plus l'inflation elle est
autour de 6% aujourd'hui en France sur
un an le ministère du travail indique
lui et bien que les salariés du privé
ont vu leur salaire augmenter en moyenne
sur un an de 3,1% donc le compte n'y est
pas on note ici que face à l'inflation
et bien les employeurs préfèrent souvent
les primes aux solutions pérennes au
sommet de l'État en tout cas et bien
c'est même pas peur nous dit Le Parisien
ce matin on ne croit guerre à cette
explosion sociale la macronie en est
persuadé les syndicats ont perdu de leur
pouvoir
mobilisateur selon un ministre cité ici
hein je cite bien sûr ouvrez les
guillemets les gens ont la tête ailleurs
il y a une inquiétude sur l'énergie
autre indiscrétion à lire ici les gens
sont lassés par deux ans de covid Le
Figaro en tout cas nous livre ça à
théorie selon laquelle cette grève pour
les salaires sera peut suivre la
stratégie est en effet contestée par
d'autres centrales syndicales
représentatives qui ont un autre
calendrier pour cette rentrée sociale
certaines d'entre elles préfèrent à
attendre que le gouvernement sorte du
bois notamment sur la réforme très
attendue des retraites voilà pour la
presse française dans le monde la presse
se pose une question ce matin qui est
derrière le sabotage des gazoduc Nord
Stream 1 et 2 oui cette question
traversée effectivement de nombreux
quotidiens internationaux ce matin alors
que certains gouvernements
occidentaux dont les pays baltes ou la
Pologne ont ouvertement accusé la Russie
d'avoir saborder ces gazoduc une réunion
du Conseil de sécurité on le sait prévu
aujourd'hui à des Russes pour preuve de
leur bonne foi mais vous allez le voir
pas de quoi convaincre regardez ce titre
du New York Times gazoduc saboter qu'il
a fait cela Russie le journal américain
note que ce sabordage s'intègre
parfaitement dans la stratégie de
Vladimir Poutine une stratégie plus
large qui consisterait à mener une
guerre sur plusieurs fronts une guerre
sur le front économique mais aussi
politique il s'agit ici d'une gare
hybride classique elle permettrait à
Moscou d'alimenter la peur chez les
Européens ce qui fait aussi monter
mécaniquement les prix du gaz mais
finalement le journal américain ne
tranche pas vraiment la question du côté
de la presse russe on se demande
pourquoi l'Occident veut-il accuser la
Russie de sapés Nord Stream c'est ce que
titre ce journal proclamera
Kremlin vice glad quel avantage aurait
Moscou à faire sauter ses propres
gazodieux que d'Amiens pour ce quotidien
de telles accusations permettent aux
Occidentaux et bien de justifier de
nouvelles sanctions et de mettre fin à
tout rétablissement de coopération à
énergétique avec la Russie ici on
souligne que ce sabotage bénéficie au
final à deux pays d'un côté l'Ukraine
qui devient ainsi mot qui détient ainsi
le monopole des approvisionnements en
gaz russe vers l'Europe et puis de
l'autre côté il y a les États-Unis qui
éliminent ainsi un concurrent au
bénéfice de ses propres exportations de
gaz liquéfié ce qui est sûr en tout cas
c'est que ça alimente les craintes en
Europe oui l'Europe étant de l'état
d'alerte c'est l'alerte justement des
Echos ce matin en raison de la
vulnérabilité de ces infrastructures
énergétiques le Vieux Continent va donc
renforcer la surveillance de ces
pipelines de ces plateformes pétrolières
de ces raffineries mais aussi de ces
lignes électriques il y a ici une sorte
de prise de conscience les
infrastructures énergétiques peuvent
devenir des cibles de cette guerre
hybride menée par par le Kremlin et puis
l'autre crainte pointée par le journal
Le Monde c'est celle d'une bombe
climatique en raison de la fuite dans
l'atmosphère de cent de milliers de
tonnes de méthane un gaz à effet de
serre au potentiel de réchauffement qui
est bien supérieur au CO2 et qui fait
craindre ici à plusieurs experts un
désastre environnemental le méthane est
responsable d'un tiers du réchauffement
climatique rapidement Sandrine se
rapporte choc très commenté sur les
dangers de l'exposition à la
pornographie chez les plus jeunes
et de l'accès à des contenus
pornographiques c'est le rapport choc de
dosenatrices qui sont à l'origine donc
de ce de ce rapport elles veulent tenter
de faire bouger les lignes leur enquête
et bien elle est sur cette alarmante
exposition des enfants à la pornographie
elle révèle que deux tiers des enfants
de moins de 15 ans un tiers de ceux qui
ont moins de 12 ans ont déjà regardé un
film pornographique voilà un rapport qui
décrit ici une génération
biberonnée je cite à des contenus
toujours plus violents dégradants et
humiliant elles veulent tenter de créer
un délit d'incitation au viol merci
beaucoup Sandrine pour cette revue de
presse et merci à vous d'avoir choisi
France 24